in this video i'm going to talk about
mass spectrometry and the physics behind
mass spectrometry
so before knowing it
let's in a simplistic manner learn what
is mass spectrometry
so mass spec is nothing
very serious mass spec is just like a
weighing machine in our normal weighing
machine we can weigh
substance in milligram range but in mass
spec machine we can weigh even molecules
so if we have a very unknown molecule a
mysterious molecule we can first start
looking at it by measuring its molecular
weight
in that respect mass spec is very
important machine for us
so what information mass spec can give
us mass pick can give us
the molecular weight
of the compound
and it can also give
this is the first
second
it can give
the molecular formula
it can
give us the formula
uh it can also give us some structural
information
it can give us some structural info
then
it can give us a
information about isotopes
then it can give us
sometimes it can give us protein
sequence but that's a special case
protein sequence
so let's see
how this mass spec works
so
here we have a mass spec machine
and
in this mass spec machine
here is the
sample insertion port
sample insertion system
so from here sample is inserted
after the sample is inserted the sample
would go
in this path and here is a huge magnet
beneath this box
and under this magnetic
field the sample will would take a
curved path
and this radius of the curved path would
be detected by a detector and ultimately
the detector would tell us about the
mass of the substance
so let's see in details
the
principles behind it so here
we have our sample and sample is
injected in
so let's say our sample is a volatile
one so it's vaporized
after our sample is in
so it is getting inside
into a specific location called the
ionizer so here the sample would be
bombarded with a
beam of electrons so the sample would be
converted into molecular ions
in this chamber the sample would be
converted into molecular ions now what
would happen sample would get in inside
and it would be deflected by special
special kind of deflectors
and it will take a path under this
magnetic field and it would take a
ultimately curved path and the radius of
this carb path would be detected by the
detector here this is the detector
this is the detector
and here we have a magnet
a powerful magnet
so here we have a magnetic field around
it and here we have electrical
deflectors
now we would try to understand the
physics behind it
so let's look at the physics
so
here we have our
ionization chamber
as i depicted earlier
so here is the sample insertion port
so from the sample insertion port sample
is inserted and now
sample is here say for instance sample
is here
now it would be bombarded
with
beam of electrons
and this uh our sample would be then
ionized
and it would be called a molecular ion
now this molecular ion
would take
a straight path
by a
region where we have a combined
electrical field and a magnetic field
say for instance we here we have a
magnetic field
which actually directs inside the plane
of the paper
here we have a magnetic field and here
is the direction of our velocity of that
particular molecular ion so now if we
analyze the force on this particular
molecular ion the magnetic force on the
particular ion
what we would denote as fb
force due to magnetic field we would
find that the direction of the for force
would be upwards
so here
we would apply our left hand thumb rule
so you can also do it
so take your index finger
and your
index finger
should point around in the direction of
the magnetic field
the next finger would point in the
direction of the velocity of that
particular ion and your thumb would
point at the direction of force
so our direction of force is actually
above
so uh this field this magnetic field
is into the plane of paper and the
magnetic force is actually balanced by
another force that is due to electrical
field and these two force are
balanced so this region is called a
velocity selector region this region is
called a
velocity
selector so actually
the magnet uh the uh molecular ion is
actually moving
under a space where we have a combined
effect of a magnetic and electric field
now
let's see
our electrical field
if e
would be
q
into times e
so q would be the charge of
the particle and e is the strength of
the electrical field and our magnetic
field would be
q times p times v
now if these two are equal then we would
have qe equal to qbv
and the q cancel out and velocity
becomes e by b
now the molecular ions that has a
particular velocity
that means v equal to e by b
can go straight
and actually
pass through a particular pore kind of
thing
and if the
if b is greater than
f e then what would happen
the particle would get
upside or if e is greater than f b then
the particle would deflected downwards
and particle cannot pass through that is
why
this region is called velocity selector
only the particles having the velocity v
equal to e times b e over b would be
selected for
further passing through a crossed
magnetic field
so now
the particle ones reach here
with a velocity v equal to e over b now
it would enter a
cross magnetic field a magnetic field
which is perpendicular
to the paint plane of paper getting
inside
so
the particle would get inside now what
happen
if we apply the same rule
that means the particle would getting
this side so this is the direction of
velocity and the magnetic field is
inside to the plane of paper so this is
p
so the force would be upward so when the
particle would get in this direction it
would be deflected
upwards
so let's see
it is deflected upwards
now it would take actually a circular
path
after taking a circular path it is
actually hitting the detector
this is our
detector
this is our detector
once it hit the detector the detector
would give us a particular data
now
the radius of this path
is very important and this radius of
this part is known
now we would do our physics
and we know when a particle does a
circular motion it should have a
centripetal force
a force a centripetal force is very
important for a circular motion
so the centrifugal force here would be
f centripetal
would be mv square by r
where v square by r would be the
acceleration
and this centripetal force is provided
by the magnetic force
so the magnetic force on the charge
particle with the velocity v would be
fb denoting at is it as fb would be bqv
and this 2 would be equal
so
bqv would be mv square by r
now this v cancel out
and the v would be
and
from here we would calculate a thing
called
mass by charge
so this mass by charge
would be
this uh
mass
by charge
would be br
uh
this mass by charge ratio
would be br by
v actually
so
oh i'm sorry
the mass by charge
would be oh okay it's br by v so we have
understanding about b we know the v and
v would be e by b and we also know the
radius so now the machine would
calculate each time the mass by
charge ratio and
from this mass by charge ratio the
machine would actually uh tell us what
is the molecular mass of the particular
compound
and it would plot it in terms of mass
per charge
versus a relative abundance
so
ultimately
by this equation the machine actually
predicts the molecular mass
so ultimately the machine would give us
a data like
so in one axis
the machine would
keep the mass bars charge ratio and in
another axis it would put the
relative abundance
with the relative abundance and we would
get for a particular
substance we would get a peak somewhere
around
and from the peak we could uh get
information about its molecular mass so
in this way
uh using a magnetic field and
accelerating a charged particle through
a magnetic field
mass spectrometry actually is able to
tell us about the molecular weight of a
particle and also it can uh tell us
about the formula of a particle
structural information and sometimes
uh which isotope is present
and these informations hope you like the
video
please subscribe
and thank you